[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
edouard husson vous êtes historien vous
dirigez également l'institut franco
allemand d'études européennes bonsoir à
vous à vos coachs et laurent péréa vous
êtes membre du conseil national du parti
communiste et vous êtes responsable
adjoint des relations internationales
notamment avec l'amérique latine bonsoir
également à vous et merci d'être là
alors hillary clinton qui fait la leçon
en tout cas qui prodigue quelques petits
conseils à joe biden russie chine mène
la danse selon elle en matière de
diplomatie vaccinale ça ne lui plaît pas
c'est une critique fondée les etats unis
se sont fait piquer le lit d'un puisque
c'est ce qu'elle semble insinuer edouard
husson
intel semble semble insinuer si vous
voulez je crois qu'il ya d'abord une
remarque de fond c'est le fait que la
capacité à fabriquer des vaccins
c'est une marque de la puissance
industrielle aujourd'hui et on remarque
que effectivement les états unis la
chine la russie sont sont en tête de
cette course on remarque aussi que la
grande bretagne après le break site a
décidé de renouer avec une ambition
industrielle et c'est un phénomène en
soi extrêmement extrêmement intéressant
on remarque aussi au passage que l'union
européenne est hors jeu largement hors
jeu et ça en dit long en fait sur les
vrais rapports de force dans le monde
dont je crois que ça c'est là la
première remarque a fait alors
qu'ensuite il y ait une diplomatie du
vaccin propre à la russie ou à la chine
qui espère effectivement gagné de l'
influence sur un certain nombre de pays
par exemple en amérique latine pour la
russie ou dans les zones d'influencé de
la chine en afrique par exemple ça c'est
évident je serais quand même prudent sur
le fait qu' il on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas à quelle vitesse la chine vaccine
vraiment et d'autre part on sait bien
que la russie actuellement elle est en
train de mettre en place des filles de
production dans d'autres pays mais ça
n'a pas
démarrer donc je crois que il s'agit
plutôt de débats internes aux milieux
dirigeants américains qui effectivement
essaye de définir une ligne politique
étrangère actuellement 1 a en tout cas
sion se focalisant sur le continent
américain je vous propose déjà de
regarder cette carte en bleu ce sont les
pays qui ont validé le ce côté qui ne
vaccinent pas tous encore avec le
spoutnik mais ils ont déjà validé 56
pays au total avec voilà pas mal de pays
en bleu en amérique du sud
on voit que le spoutnik et 30 autres aux
portes des états unis clairement le
brésil a signé un contrat mais n'est pas
encore validé on le sait d'ailleurs on
l'a appris il ya quelques temps les
états unis font pression sur brasilia de
pour ne pas produire ce vaccin russe
sagen clairement laurent péréa cette
influence entre guillemets un traité au
vaccin russe en amérique du sud ça gêne
les américains je crois que dalle mort
dans leur stratégie a effectué un
parcours la situation pandémique des
états unis roux le forcing et contenait
les décisions les couleurs américaines
c'est de jouer court pour soi en bois
bien j'ai envie de dire la diplomatie
des masques tu passais la diplomatie de
dire ça
ces populations on assiste à un accident
mondialement et puis dire et quelque
part ça on voit comment aujourd'hui aux
politiques et de fractures regarde et on
voit ce que voter on voit bien que les
meilleurs ne joue pour que pour l'europe
au max l essai l'égard de celle de ce
que fait les états unis
lire sur un autre domaine y compris au
niveau européen on voit bien comment
alors que nous on n'est pas capable de
produire aujourd'hui nos vaccins
on est en train d'essayer de protéger
pour 4 astrazeneca lepailleur et de
l'autre certains ouvrent quelque part je
dirais des bresse dans le le cas
occidental est quelque part colonise
médical par des continents et on le voit
comme l'afrique l'amérique latine voire
l'asie et à ce scénario on éprouve ce
que vous disiez est ce qui était tout à
l'heure on y trouve la chine
on y trouve la russie aujourd'hui on y
trouve aussi l'aisne s'ils ne
participent pas à la fête des mères le
voir pour de taxe est égale je dirais la
vaccination pour tout le monde sur la
planète par le mécanisme au bac et donc
la chine investit cdc discours là dedans
et quel est son accès il pouvait avoir
la bonne personne de christian un bien
public mondial qui en temps normal
jusqu'à aujourd'hui fabriqués là
pratiquement la moitié des vaccins de la
planète
aujourd'hui l'on pouvait c'est vrai que
le 15 mars à la chine annoncé donné par
exemple 300 mille doses de vaccin aux
casques bleus avec je suis une priorité
pour se déployer justement edouard
husson nous l'expliquait en afrique
c'est une manière de gagner de l'
influence sur ce continent très convoité
on sait laurent péréa je pense que c'est
un moyen
déjà qu'on saura profit de de ses alliés
et y compris pour précis de doué à
l'avenir des meilleures relations je
dirais commercial dans le système
aujourd'hui j'ai à dire le jeudi que les
mécanismes libéraux ils reprennent vite
alors leur place et on voit bien
aujourd'hui comment le bassin il peut
servir à ça et notamment
sur certaines pays qu'on regarde où il
ya les richesses de sol à exploiter le
derrière pour l'avenir il n'y a pas que
la chine n'y a pas que la russie aussi
israël
on l'apprenait en préparant cette
émission par exemple qui vient de faire
don de 100 mille doses de modern art en
contrepartie de leur soutien aux pays
qui ont ouvert des missions
diplomatiques à jérusalem où se sont
engagés à le faire
clairement le vaccin edouard husson
c'est de la géopolitique de la
diplomatie une sorte de vrais pouvoirs
finalement oui je crois si vous voulez
ce qui est très intéressant dans ce qui
se passe c'est le décalage entre la
situation réelle de la de la vaccination
à l'échelle mondiale d'ailleurs c'est et
rappelé l instant là les pays qui peut
être si l'on admet que les vaccins soit
efficace aurait le plus besoin ne sont
pas forcément les premiers servis il est
certain que il y a eu une attitude de
grande efficacité à la fois internes aux
états unis déjà démarré sous donald
trump et puis en grande-bretagne pour
vacciner sa propre population c'est le
cas d'israël aussi et à partir de là des
pays comme les trois que je viens de
citer sont en mesure de choisir où
effectivement envoyé des doses de
vaccins dont il n'aurait plus lusage et
c'est à ce titre là que effectivement il
sera elle entre aussi dans ce que vous
appelez là la diplomatie du vaccin
je demande simplement si vous voulez je
crois pourtant on parle des choses
telles qu'elles sont qu'on soit très
attentifs au fait qu'il y a énormément d
fed annonce et il faudrait à chaque fois
qu à une annonce de ce type à les
vérifier
quelques semaines après ou quelques mois
après ce qui a été réellement fait et je
pense que c'est particulièrement visible
dans le cas de la de la diplomatie
chinoise dont on sait qu'elle est
particulièrement opaque depuis les
origines de la cuisse du pôle vide
depuis que le virus a éclaté dans la
région de voile alors je voulais qu'on
s'intéresse aussi à la population
ce qu'en pensent les gens tout
simplement un peu partout dans le monde
je voudrais vous faire commenter ce
sondage yougov paru cet après-midi sur
les préférences en matière de choix de
vaccins les personnes interrogées elles
sont dans 9 pays différents et bien
c'est la russie et les etats-unis qui
sont clairement identifiées comme les
deux fabricants les plus fiables 54 %
des interrogés ont désigné la russie
donc comme le pays producteurs de
vaccins qui inspire le plus confiance
sept personnes interrogées sur 10 74%
donc disent connaître le vaccin russe
clairement de laurent péréa il ya aussi
une affaire d'image qui se joue là
dedans même auprès de tout simplement de
la popularité des populations et pas que
des de la géopolitique et des états
disent aucun cas un moment je dirais aux
dans un climat anxiogène haut niveau au
niveau international on le voit bien
avec avec un pmi compris avec les drames
les drames que sacrée derrière avec
soient sociaux ou économiques et d
égalité sociale à même temps qui monte
très fort il y a en même temps une âme
vie qui monte de politique de solidarité
je dirais des nouvelles qui sont
renforcées contre le mur quelque part de
ce qui est de faire des profits qui est
réduit de plus en plus insupportable et
effectivement que dans ce contexte la
l'a8 se faire vacciner de se sortir de
cette situation aujourd'hui
elle attire les regards vers skipper
qui peut être l'espoir et a même temps
vu le bancs de la provision de main qui
est lié de façon très inégale au niveau
de la planète la russie certainement et
convie la chine peuvent apparaître
effectivement font de ce qu'ils peuvent
être gravés commerce portage société dia
bâ il faudra veiller au travers des
effets d'annoncé il faudra vérifier
comment une société concrétise derrière
on voit bien où pour moi aujourd'hui la
russie elle risque se retrouver
confronté à ne pouvoir honorer qui
combine les commandes qui sont ils sont
passés mais il y avait une question qui
est posée d'un nouvel internationalisme
et que le vaccin ils sont pas utilisés
quelque part comme une arme de
concurrence pour l'avenir et donc c'est
pour ça que la diplomatie vaccinale elle
porte en elle je dirais des effets
pervers
au lieu de permettre d etat je dirais de
travailler de concert sur une production
de distribution et d'administration du
fax hier la planète aujourd'hui on voit
comment s'est redressé à rappeler
quelque part les épingle du jeu la
vaccination est donc je pense qu'il ya
besoin de travailler sur ses axes là
certains parlent aujourd'hui parce que
je je dirais même que certains parlent
de nouvelle coopération y compris la
phase parle qu'il faudrait inventer de
nouvelles coopérations notamment par
rapport à ces question de la vaccination
mais souvent quand on regarde dans la
réalité ils s'inscrivent plus dassin
dans l'invention d'une nouvelle posture
et je crois que c'était les échos qui le
cite l autre jour c'est celle de la
compétition c'est à dire en fait composé
de maëstricht avantages et bénéfices aux
dernières que c'est c'est renoncer je
dirais à éradiquer la pratique ni à
l'échelle mondiale et c'est pour ça que
l'attitude des big pharmas même temps
aujourd'hui
ayant découvert le médecin je ne sais
pas qui c'est
c'est pour eux je pense qu il ya besoin
de nouvelles diplôme
et de nouveaux mécanismes à l'échelle
internationale quand on sait notamment
que sur 12 milliards d'euros qui ont été
investis dans la postérité mondiale qui
lie à ce sont des formules et donc il ya
une question qui est posée c'est
qu'elles font mal
les brevets sont utilisés aujourd'hui là
j'étais dans le sanitaire at elle a
vraiment une diplomatie vaccinale
procédure le lycée et je tire et un au
nom de l'article 30 existe oblige à nice
lui faveur mais les formules de leurs
vaccins aux pays qui le demande afin que
les vaccins contre la copie puisse de
lien entre guillemets générique est donc
accessible à tous et je pense que là il
ya des choses qu'on pardonnez moi le mot
de la fin pour vous pardonnez moi de
vous couper la chique laurent péréa mais
c'est vrai c'est le mot de la fin c'est
un certain décryptage à 2 alors au
revoir on ne sait pas vous dîtes moscou
qui sera peut-être lui aussi un
confrontés à des problèmes
d'approvisionnement il n'empêche la
russie promet 50 millions de doses à
l'europe si elle les commandes
ma dernière question pour vous edouard
husson on pourra se passer du vaccin
russes par exemple comme l'affirment
thierry breton écoutez je crois que
effectivement ce qu'est ce qu'elle était
étonnant dans les derniers jours c'est
là c'est la volte face de thierry breton
qui la semaine dernière
chantait les louanges du vaccin russe et
puis tout d'un coup avant-hier a décidé
que ce vaccin n'était plus câble ou en
tout cas que la russie ne serait pas en
mesure d'après d'approvisionner l'union
européenne
alors je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya
derrière lens et ne cherchent pas
forcément à comprendre mais je ne pense
que ça n'est pas forcément l'opinion
d'autres pays européens l'allemagne
souhaitent s'approvisionner en vaccins
russe parce que les allemands
considèrent que la vaccination et
l'approvisionnement ne va pas assez vite
la hongrie a déjà indiqué aussi quelques
elle le faisait ces procurer des doses
donc
si vous voulez il y a là aussi dans le
cas de l'union européenne il va y avoir
une diplomatie interne du vaccin entre
les pays européens
et de ce point de vue là c'est vrai que
là la volte-face de monsieur breton n'a
pas été étant donné qu'il est essentiel
que monsieur vaccin de la commission
européenne dire des choses
contradictoires à quelques jours
d'intervalle n'a pas contribué à mettre
de la confiance parmi les citoyens de
l'union européenne
merci en tout cas tous les deux et
douars huchon laurent péréa d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france